[Aplausos]
[Música]
cada vez que nos hablan de México es muy
probable que pensemos en tacos tequila y
mariachis hay esa rancheras Pero por
desgracia también es muy probable que en
un instante después pensemos también en
violencia narcotráfico y crimen
organizado de hecho este mismo año 2023
ha empezado con una noticia que ha dado
la vuelta al mundo fijaos 6 de enero de
2023 El cartel de Sinaloa lanzó una
violenta respuesta cuando México
recaptura al hijo del Chapo y ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando muchos hombre
Fonseca que detengan un arco en
principio es una buena noticia verdad
Pues sí pero sus consecuencias
inmediatas pueden no serlo tanto porque
cuando cae un pez gordo del crimen
organizado de repente se desatan enormes
olas de violencia a las que tristemente
muchos mexicanos ya se han acostumbrado
la realidad mis queridos amigos de
visualpolitik Es que la violencia está
tan arraigada en la sociedad mexicana
que incluso ya forma parte de la cultura
popular Sí hemos hablado antes de las
ran pero también existe otro género en
la música mexicana Los narcocorridos que
son canciones que cuentan las historias
de los narcos a quienes en muchos casos
se les presenta de manera heroica esto
ya da la medida de Hasta qué punto el
narco está tan presente en la sociedad
mexicana seamos honestos Aunque México
es mucho más que todo eso
desgraciadamente tiene bastante sentido
que asociamos este país con el mundo de
narcotráfico Al fin y al cabo es su
puerta natural de entrada al gigantesco
y codiciado mercado de los Estados
Unidos a los narcos les viene que ni
pintado estar tan cerca del mayor centro
de consumo mundial de narcóticos tiene
lógica verdad Pero esperad un momento
porque esto por sí solo no explica
Porque hay tanta violencia en México por
qué pues echad un vistazo a este mapa
[Música]
lo que estáis viendo en pantalla es un
mapa que divide la ciudad del paso en
Texas Estados Unidos y Ciudad Juárez en
México este punto ha sido siempre
considerado como uno de los más
calientes de todo el narcotráfico
americano Pero y si os dijera que El
Paso Texas está considerada como una de
las grandes ciudades más seguras de los
Estados Unidos mientras que en cambio
Ciudad Juárez es una de las más
violentas de todo México es más Ciudad
Juárez fue considerada en el año 2021
como la segunda ciudad Mexicana con
mayor número de homicidios por cada
100.000 habitantes Entonces el problema
no puede ser solamente el narcotráfico
nos parece pues por ahí van los tiros
nunca Mejor dicho para muchos el
auténtico problema de este país no son
en sí mismo los narcos sino sobre todo
la debilidad y la corrupción de muchas
de las instituciones mexicanas incluso
muchos expertos apuntan que gran parte
de México bien Podría considerarse como
un estado fallido un estado donde muchos
ciudadanos confían antes en el orden que
impone el narco que en el orden que
impone el estado a la policía quizás el
problema sea que muchas de estas zonas
el estado no pinta prácticamente nada y
todo el control de facto está en manos
de estos mismos narcos así como para
hacerles frente
[Música]
Y tal vez por eso desde que en el año
2000 el gobierno mexicano empezará a
enfrentarse al narcotráfico de manera
directa la violencia se halla disparado
y hoy es ya con mucha diferencia el
mayor problema del país al mayor
problema y también una de las mayores
prioridades del actual presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador la pregunta por
tanto que podemos hacernos hoy es por
qué sigue Habiendo tanta violencia en
México hasta qué punto tienen poder los
carteles mexicanos qué éxitos está
cosechando Realmente amlo si es que esta
cosechando algún éxito hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
enemigos
[Música]
íntimos
en general la relación entre
narcotraficantes y gobiernos ha sido
bastante turbia Y tormentosa a lo largo
de la historia nunca sabes lo que te vas
a encontrar por ejemplo desde que
Estados Unidos declaró la guerra contra
las drogas en 1971 bajo la presidencia
de Richard Nixon decenas y decenas de
gobiernos de todo el mundo han
multiplicado sus esfuerzos para intentar
acabar con los narcos sin embargo la
cruda realidad es que todos estos
esfuerzos no han servido para gran cosa
los narcos siguen colocando su mercancía
a diestro y siniestro a lo largo de
Europa Estados Unidos y en general el
mundo entero lo que explica por ejemplo
que los precios de la droga en la calle
se hayan mantenido razonablemente
estables Durante los últimos años
hablamos de toda una gigantesca
industria mil millonaria cuyas redes de
poder llegan a salpicar a quienes se
supone que tienen que enfrentarse a
ellos la situación es tal que incluso se
cree que la Cia el FBI o la propia DEA
de los Estados Unidos han llegado a
permitir la entrada de narcóticos en
Estados Unidos para poder atrapar a los
peces gordos ahora bien si hay un país
donde con el paso del tiempo se ha hecho
más la colaboración entre estado
políticos y narcos Ese es precisamente
México sin ir más lejos uno de los
partidos con más escándalos y
acusaciones por sus nexos con el narco
no es otro que el partido revolucionario
institucional más conocido como el pri
[Música]
claro hablamos de un partido que ha
controlado el gobierno de México durante
más de 60 años y eso queridos amigos es
mucho tiempo tanto como para poder hacer
amigos Incluso en el mismísimo infierno
y de hecho Si por algo se ha
caracterizado la historia del Pri es por
estar plagada de todo tipo de
acusaciones de fraude electoral y sobre
todo de corrupción pero no de cualquier
corrupción sino de la corrupción
vinculada al narcotráfico y al crimen
organizado queréis un ejemplo pues ahí
tenemos casos como el de Raúl Salinas de
Gortari que es uno de los hermanos del
expresidente Salinas de Gortari y que se
vio seriamente involucrado en
corruptelas con el Cartel del Golfo en
los años 80 fue arrestado en el año 1995
ahora bien durante las seis décadas de
gobiernos del Pri la narco violencia
nunca llegó a ser un problema al menos
nunca llegó a ser un problema tan grave
como lo es hoy en día así que la
pregunta es que ha cambiado pues veréis
durante el tiempo en el que el pri
estuvo en el poder se establecía una
especie de pacto no escrito por el que
los narcos gozaban de cierta libertad de
actuación siempre y cuando no sembraron
el caos en el país es decir que si se
portaban más o menos podían hacer lo que
les dieron la real gana y de hecho el
pri dio una oportunidad de oro para
perpetuarse de esta manera en el poder
porque gracias a la manga ancha con los
narcotraficantes y el crimen organizado
estos le garantizaban cierta Paz social
sin embargo su vecino del Norte es decir
los Estados Unidos no estaba
precisamente satisfecho con este papel
para los gringos la lucha contra las
drogas era una cuestión crucial y lo era
incluso desde antes de que Nixon
declarase oficialmente la guerra contra
el narco
por ejemplo ya en 1948 tuvo lugar la
primera campaña de Exterminio de
cultivos de opiáceos en México pero ojo
porque aquí no termina todo desde 1948
al pri le tocó hacer malabares entre los
intereses de Estados Unidos y los del
pri Y eso que frecuentemente apuntaban a
direcciones contrarias por eso A pesar
de que los gobiernos del Pri llevaron a
cabo operaciones tan conocidas como la
Cóndor de los años 70 para perseguir a
los narcos y desmantelar cultivos en los
altos del Sinaloa en realidad no se les
hizo mucho daño digamos que estas
operaciones funcionaron más bien como
una forma de calmar a Estados Unidos y
convencerles de que México por fin se
había puesto las pilas y mientras tanto
los propios gerifaltes políticos
mexicanos disfrutaban de todo su poder
Eso sí siempre y cuando no molestarán a
las mafias y carteles locales ambos
ganaban y nadie se quejaba más o menos
las cosas funcionaban el problema El
problema es que tarde o temprano los
narcos Se volvieron tan asquerosamente
ricos que empezaron a tener cada vez más
influencia sobre gran parte de la
ciudadanía mexicana y claro es justo en
ese momento cuando los políticos del Pri
se dieron cuenta de que los narcos
podían convertirse en toda una
competencia para ese poder político y
militar del propio estado y ahí es
cuando decidieron ponerse a luchar de
una vez por todas contra ellos el
problema Pues que quizás en México ese
momento llegó demasiado tarde atentos
la guerra total
[Música]
nuevo siglo nuevo gobierno eso debieras
de pensar los mexicanos porque nada más
empezar el año 2000 un nuevo presidente
tomó el poder Vicente Fox del Pri pues
no por primera vez después de seis
décadas el pri perdió el poder y la
sustituyó el pan el partido de Acción
Nacional que se hizo con las riendas
tras celebrarse el primer traspaso
Pacífico de gobierno en México desde la
revolución de principios del siglo XX
paréntesis para que os ubiquéis un poco
si no estáis familiarizados con la
política mexicana el pri sería el
partido de Centro izquierda más o menos
Mientras que el pan sería el partido del
centro derecha fin del paréntesis
comenzaba entonces una nueva época y con
ella una nueva política frente a los
narcos el nuevo presidente Vicente Fox
se alineó con los intereses de los
Estados Unidos Y puso en marcha una
enorme ofensiva contra el crimen
organizado y no precisamente como las
del Pri que buscaban más aparentar que
ser realmente efectivas no esta vez era
de verdad el ejército comenzó a tener un
papel más destacado en la lucha contra
las drogas y de hecho el gobierno de Fox
aprobó una nueva ley de seguridad
nacional que le daba más capacidad al
ejército para actuar en asuntos civiles
en tiempo de paz desde entonces fue
directo a por los capos de los carteles
por eso durante su presidencia no fue
extraño Ver noticias como esta México
golpea el narcotráfico con la captura
del jefe del Cártel de Tijuana y ya sé
lo que estaréis pensando muchos pues
esto es una buena noticia verdad por fin
el estado se pone manos a la obra pues
la realidad es que su estrategia de
utilizar el ejército y escalar la lucha
contra los narcos dio algunos frutos
dulces Sí pero también otros muy amargos
el tráfico de drogas de Estados Unidos
no se frenó sino que incluso siguió
creciendo Pero además los carteles se
fragmentaron y de repente las tasas de
evidencia se elevaron como un cohete al
final durante la presidencia de Fox el
número de nuevos cárteles y grupos
criminales organizados creció como la
espuma digamos que caía un capo y
surgían dos y ojo Porque si pensáis que
la situación no podía ser peor estáis
muy pero que muy equivocados Porque
después de Vicente Fox llegó Felipe
Calderón y la lucha se intensificó de
hecho Calderón es el presidente que
proclamó formalmente México la guerra
contra las drogas y lo hizo mano a mano
con los Estados Unidos gracias a la
llamada iniciativa Mérida y En qué
consistía su estrategia Pues básicamente
en luchar frontalmente contra los narcos
y ojo porque cuando digo frontalmente
digo luchar con todos los recursos
posibles como si se tratara de una
guerra de verdad la violencia se disparó
aún más y lo que es aún peor el estado
no pudo ganar esta guerra en el año 2012
de repente parecía que todo se iba a
parar de golpe y plumazo Y diréis por
qué Pues porque ese año volvió el pri al
poder esta vez de la mano de Enrique
Peña Nieto y la verdad es que las cosas
cambiaron pero a peor fijaos en esta
gráfica este nuevo gobierno del Pri
registró las cifras más sangrientas de
la historia mexicana con Vicente Fox el
número de homicidios anuales se mantuvo
más o menos estable con Calderón
empezaron a subir como la espuma pero
con Peña Nieto digamos que batieron
todos los récords en el año 2018 no
parecía que hubieran nada que hacer y
entonces en 2018 apareció esa figura que
prometía cambiar por completo La
estrategia de seguridad nacional atentos
[Música]
abrazos no balazos
a estas alturas de la película que un
líder populista se convierta en el
presidente de un país latinoamericano es
que no es noticia Esta es la tierra
perfecta para las cosechas de populistas
desde Hugo Chávez hasta Cristina de
kirchner pasando por Rafael Correa Evo
Morales Gustavo Petro nayib bukele estoy
seguro de que son nombres que no nos
pillan por sorpresa y sabéis que México
no es la excepción el año 2018 llegó a
la presidencia mexicana El ya conocido a
Andrés Manuel López Obrador también
llamado por sus siglas amlo hijo de
comerciantes descendientes de españoles
e indígenas amlo comenzó su andadura en
la política paradójicamente con el pri
sin embargo después de las fraudulentas
elecciones de 1988 se pasó al partido de
la Revolución democrática con el que
llegó a ser jefe de gobierno del
Distrito Federal entre los años 2000 y
2005 a partir de Entonces poco a poco su
popularidad fue creciendo hasta que
finalmente en 2018 al tercer intento
ganó las elecciones presidenciales y ojo
porque amlo tradicionalmente solo ha
destacado por sus mensajes su Estilo
populista o incluso sus excentricidades
pero es que también ha destacado por el
discurso que lleva décadas defendiendo
contra la supuesta estrategia
militarista que han empleado los
diferentes gobiernos mexicanos en su
lucha contra el narco de hecho el nombre
de su estrategia de seguridad es
tremendamente pegadizo fijaos
[Aplausos]
que yo hable de abrazos y no balazos
yo digo que voy a seguir sosteniendo lo
mismo ustedes creen que solo deteniendo
a capos se va a resolver el problema
no Claro que
si los encontramos los detenemos
pero el propósito Es atender las causas
abrazos no balazos a que suena muy
bonito verdad sin embargo como ya os
podéis imaginar el éxito del eslogan no
se ha trasladado en la práctica ni
muchísimo menos fijaos los homicidios
descienden pero el sexenio de amlo se
perfila como el más violento desde que
amlo se hizo con el poder no ha logrado
reducir demasiado las tasas de
criminalidad de hecho en los dos
primeros años de su presidencia 2019 y
2020 se reportaron casi el mismo número
de homicidios que en el fatídico último
año de Enrique Peña Nieto y de hecho al
final su promesa de desmilitarizar la
Seguridad Ciudadana y de Volver al
ejército a los cuarteles que también en
uno de sus eslóganes cayó en saco roto Y
es que de hecho amlo ha cambiado tanto
de opinión que su proyecto estrella la
guardia nacional ha dejado de ser una
institución con mando civil para ser
dirigida por el Sedena es decir la
secretaría de la defensa nacional dicho
de otra forma que ha militarizado la
guardia nacional que él mismo creó en el
año 2019 precisamente para sacar al
ejército de las calles y no solo eso
ahora incluso está del tareas civiles en
el ejército
a ver Es verdad que esto del arte del
donde dije digo digo Diego no es nada
nuevo en México pero sí que llama la
atención viniendo de amlo un líder que
puso tanto énfasis durante toda su
carrera política en la desmilitarización
de la seguridad pública ahora sin
embargo es todo lo contrario incluso
está poniendo las fuerzas armadas por
las nubes atentos
la dependencia más preparada para
defender la soberanía y enfrentar las
amenazas del contrabando y la
introducción de droga Andrés Manuel
López Obrador el problema es que con
tanto elogio el presidente olvida la
corrupción sin ir más lejos en octubre
de 2022 salieron a la luz los llamados
guacamaya leaks que expusieron decenas
de miles de emails conversaciones y
expedientes oficiales del Sedena
expedientes y conversaciones sobre todo
tipo de asuntos desde la propia salud de
amlo hasta los negocios del ejército que
ahora se encarga también de la
construcción de infraestructuras por eso
no es extraño que nos encontremos con
noticias como esta militares son
acusados de irregularidades financieras
en la construcción de sucursales del
banco del y tampoco podemos olvidar que
a lo largo de su historia el Ejército
mexicano se ha visto envuelto en graves
acusaciones por violar los derechos
humanos en cierto modo es lo que suele
pasar cuando mezclas armas poder y
corrupción la duda ahora es le está
mereciendo la pena amlo hacer
exactamente todo lo contrario a lo que
prometió en materia de seguridad o dicho
de otra manera está funcionando esta
nueva estrategia de seguridad de amlo
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
tanques
[Música]
los tanques y los blindados son una cosa
muy 2023 aunque solo sea porque se
espera que Ucrania reciba decenas y
decenas de tanques Durante este año pero
incluso Antes de que los vendados
militares se pusieran tan de moda los
narcos ya le habían echado un ojo a esta
posibilidad atentos utilizar blindados
para consolidar su poder territorial en
México habéis oído bien A ver es cierto
que no son blindados fabricados por la
sofisticada industria militar
estadounidense sino algo Bastante más de
andar por casa pero ojo porque siguen
siendo peligrosos estoy hablando de los
llamados narcotanques bichos como este y
ya sé lo que os estaréis preguntando
pero a ver si hasta los narcos tienen ya
sus propios tanques caseros realmente es
posible que amlo pueda mejorar la
seguridad del país pues en principio las
cifras dicen que sí no mucho pero algo
es algo desde la llegada de López
Obrador el crimen ha seguido muy activo
tal y como ocurrió con sus predecesores
sin embargo también es cierto que en
2021 consiguió que los homicidios
disminuyeran un 4,3% con respecto al
anterior y lo que es aún mejor en 2021
se produjeron de media unos 26,6
homicidios por cada 100.000 habitantes
es decir nueve homicidios más por cada
100.000 habitantes que en 2015 por otro
lado los casos de delitos graves y de
secuestro han seguido manteniendo la
tendencia a la baja que iniciaron en el
año 2019 a ver no nos malinterpretéis la
verdad es que los datos siguen siendo
desoladores y la estrategia de
militarización sigue siendo un pozo sin
fondo que no consigue los resultados
esperados
[Música]
quizás derrotar a los narcos va a
necesitar de otros métodos y aquí es
donde tenemos en cuenta que el propio
funcionamiento de los carteles hace que
sea muy difícil acabar con ellos no
olvidéis que utilizan métodos de combate
y armas cada vez más avanzadas hablamos
de los narcotanques Sí pero también de
drones o incluso de armamento utilizado
por la propia Infantería estadounidense
como las ametralladoras Browning m2 de
Calibre 50 y claro si a esto le unimos
que las instituciones mexicanas no
llegan a todo el país Es lógico que los
carteles no desaparezcan es más
recordáis cuando al principio de este
vídeo os contamos la detención Guzmán es
decir el hijo del Chapo Guzmán Pues bien
Ovidio es el capo del Cartel De Sinaloa
desde que México extraditó a su padre a
los Estados Unidos en 2017 y la pregunta
es creéis que aunque hayan detenido a
Ovidio Guzmán El cartel de Sinaloa va a
dejar de traficar con drogas extorsionar
a quien le interese otra picar con
personas Exacto lo habéis adivinado Por
supuesto que no y es que este es uno de
los puntos clave del narcotráfico y del
crimen organizado actual en México Ya no
son organizaciones piramidales ahora
tienen una organización descentralizada
con puntos que trabajan de manera
independiente es decir que si cae el
líder ya no cae el equipo al completo
sino que en la práctica todo sigue más o
menos como si no hubiera pasado
absolutamente nada
[Música]
así que todo apunta a que la estrategia
de amlo va a resultar otro fracaso más
en la ya larga lucha contra el narco
mexicano y ojo hablamos de fracaso No
porque no haya conseguido alguna mejora
ya hemos visto que eso no es así en
cualquier caso los carteles están muy
pero que muy bien blindados y el estado
mexicano no cuenta con una estrategia
capaz de hacerles frente para diezmarlos
de una vez por todas esa idea de amlo de
abrazos y no balazos no está cosechando
sus frutos y México sigue siendo uno de
los países más peligrosos del mundo en
los que los narcos no solo dan balazos
sino también bombazos y secuestros Esta
es la terrible realidad que se vivió en
México pero ahora la pregunta es para ti
crees que amlo logrará darle la vuelta a
la tortilla antes de abandonar la
presidencia qué alternativa la
militarización crees que podemos
encontrar sale de verdad a cuenta la
guerra contra las drogas podéis dejarnos
vuestra respuesta aquí abajo en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
Que aquí en visualpolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]